[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa este es el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
empezamos hablando de todo el continente
porque hay una pugna por las
invitaciones a la cumbre de las américas
el anuncio del anfitrión de no tener la
intención de invitar a las
representaciones de cuba- venezuela en
nicaragua por no tener regímenes
democráticos ha desatado una ola de
llamados de presidentes con ideologías
más o menos similares para que se les
incluya les contamos de quienes se trata
y bajamos al sur a colombia porque el
asesinato de marcelo pecci un fiscal
paraguayo que investigaba casos de
narcotráfico lavado de dinero y crimen
organizado en su país
conmociona a las autoridades de ambas
naciones que pidieron ayuda a eeuu para
investigar
y seguimos en ecuador porque la corte
constitucional reconoció en enero que
los animales silvestres son sujetos de
derecho de la mano de nuestro
corresponsal en quitó conocemos cómo se
trabaja para preservar la vida de ellos
ahora
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal falta menos de un mes
para la cumbre de las américas que en su
novena edición vuelve al país en donde
tuvo lugar la primera eeuu en 1994
entonces bajo la administración de bill
clinton y que tenía un espíritu de unión
que incluso buscaba crear un área de
libre comercio entre nuestras naciones
hoy ese espíritu ha desaparecido para
dar lugar a una especie de boicot por
parte de los mandatarios con ideologías
de izquierda en rechazo a la decisión
del anfitrión el presidente joe biden de
no invitar a cuba- a nicaragua ni a
venezuela debido a sus prácticas
antidemocráticas
a la voz de rechazo que andrés manuel
lópez obrador alzó el nombre de mexico
se sumaron bolivia argentina y honduras
veamos más en el siguiente informe que
preparamos para ustedes
a
un sentimiento que al parecer no
comparte su sucesor y entonces
vicepresidente joe biden aunque las
invitaciones no se han hecho oficiales
eeuu dijo que no tiene intención de
invitar a los representantes de cuba
miguel díaz-canel de venezuela nicolás
maduro ni de nicaragua daniel ortega a
la cumbre de las américas que tendrá
lugar en los ángeles porque ellos no
representan a sus ciudadanos en
respuesta a países con ideologías
cercanas empezaron a presionar a la casa
blanca insistiré con el presidente baile
en que no se excluye a ningún país de
américa
en la cumbre
del mes próximo a celebrarse en los
ángeles california
y que las autoridades de cada país
decidan libremente
si asisten o no a dicho encuentro pero
que nadie excluya a nadie al mandatario
mexicano se sumaron el presidente de
bolivia luis arce la presidenta de
honduras xiomara castró y el argentino
alberto fernández que en un tono más
moderado pidió incluirlos por su parte
cuba denunció un revés en las relaciones
hemisféricas la exclusión de cuba que se
avisora
constituiría un grave retroceso
histórico en relación con las dos
cumbres anteriores en las que cuba
participó en pie de igualdad
en respuesta a washington finalmente
matizó y dijo que es poco probable que
se les invite sin embargo con esta
suerte de boicot al encuentro se pone en
riesgo una plataforma para lograr
acuerdos con miras a solucionar los
flagelos de la región como la migración
récords la reactivación de las economías
post pandemia la lucha contra el cambio
climático e incluso compromisos con la
democracia antes cambiamos de tema pero
seguimos hablando de cooperación
transnacional
paraguay eeuu iniciaron una
investigación conjunta por el asesinato
del fiscal especializado paraguayo
marcelo pecci en la isla colombiana de
barú mientras estaba de luna de miel el
fiscal investigaba casos de narcotráfico
crimen organizado y lavado de dinero en
su país bogotá y asunción han trabajado
conjuntamente durante varios años contra
los cárteles de las drogas pero su
espectro aún ensombrece a ambas naciones
en un ataque típico de los cárteles del
narcotráfico
así es como un colega del fiscal
paraguayo marcelo pecci describió su
asesinato en colombia durante una
conversación con france24 en realidad el
fiscal marcelo pecci con un grupo de
fiscales llevaba a cabo varias
investigaciones importantes es por eso
que informalmente los aviones que se
está conectando tratando de conectar en
un trabajo conjunto también con las
autoridades colombianas si es que cuál
de esas causas sería el motivo de este
atentado que ocurrió había fecha y
recibió dos disparos por parte de dos
hombres que iban a bordo de una moto
acuática frente a las playas de la isla
de barú cercana a cartagena donde pasaba
su luna de miel
pezzi quien tenía 45 años y la
periodista claudia aguilera se casaron
el 30 de abril el conversado con el
presidente iván duque por teléfono
se comprometió conmigo para darnos todo
nuestro apoyo para resolver el caso para
buscar a los responsables
el fiscal que investigaba crímenes de
narcotráfico y lavado de dinero cobró
fama internacional cuando llegó el caso
de ronaldinho quien intentó entrar a
paraguay con un pasaporte falso antes de
morir estaba investigando un atentado
durante un festival en paraguay que
ocurrió mientras tocaba una banda
colombiana en un país donde la
corrupción es rampante marcelo pecci era
conocido por su transparencia desempeña
un papel destacado en varias operaciones
importantes contra el crimen organizado
y el blanqueo de capitales la policía
colombiana ha prometido casi 490.000
dólares a quien ayude a encontrar e
identificar a los asesinos del fiscal
colombia sigue ocupando el primer lugar
como el mayor productor mundial de
cocaína actualmente se enfrenta a un
aumento de la violencia relacionado con
los cárteles de la droga
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden decidió renovar una ley que data
de la segunda guerra mundial para ayudar
a los ucranianos a vencer al ejército de
vladimir putin la misma ley que ayudó
entonces a la unión soviética a vencer a
los nazis da un giro de 180 grados para
vencer ahora a los rusos
con apenas el trazo de una pluma eeuu ha
hecho que enviara armas y ayuda a
ucrania sea mucho más fácil
estoy firmando un proyecto de ley que
crea una herramienta en nuestros
esfuerzos de apoyar al gobierno de
ucrania y al pueblo ucraniano en su
lucha para defender a su maíz y la
democracia en contra de la guerra brutal
de putin la ley de defensa de la
democracia de ucrania de 2022 es
esencialmente una actualización de la
legislación de la era de la segunda
guerra mundial que le permitió a la
unión americana ayudar a los aliados y a
las naciones que luchaban contra la
alemania nazi bajo los términos de la
nueva ley washington puede prestar o
rentar equipo militar a ucrania y a
otras naciones europeas afectadas por la
guerra rusa con menos trámites
democráticos la ayuda tampoco responderá
a la capacidad de pago de kiev
hace más de ocho décadas eeuu presentó
el programa de préstamo arriendo para
ayudar y enviar armas a reino unido y
otras naciones que combatían a adolf
hitler y los nazis entre ellos estaba la
entonces unión soviética mientras rusia
celebra su rol en la derrota de la
alemania nazi el kremlin reflexiona que
la victoria llegó con la ayuda de los
estadounidenses como el mismo joseph
stalin lo dijo bajo el programa original
de préstamo y arriendo eeuu transfirió a
la unión soviética siete mil tanques 51
mil chips
376 mil camiones 132 mil ametralladoras
así como comida y ropa cuando rusia
invadió ucrania justificó su decisión al
decir que era necesaria para
desclasificar al país ahora un programa
que alguna vez les ayudó a derrotar el
fascismo será utilizado para ayudar a
kiev a detener la agresión rusa
vamos a quedarnos en el norte del
continente para revisar otras noticias
de las américas que ustedes deberían
conocer esta semana el ex presidente de
honduras juan orlando hernández se
declaró no culpable de los tres cargos
relacionados con el narcotráfico y el
porte de armas que se le imputaron en
una corte de nueva york la defensa del
ex mandatario de honduras quiere citar a
donald trump y al mismísimo
narcotraficante mexicano joaquín el
chapo guzmán para que testifiquen a su
favor dice que se trata de una de
venganza de los cárteles precisamente
por combatirlos no obstante su hermano
tony fue condenado por esa misma corte a
cadena perpetua por narcotráfico en 2021
en mexico la autopsia solicitada por la
familia al cuerpo de la joven de baní
escobar reveló que fue abusada
sexualmente y posteriormente asesinada
la joven desapareció en abril y fue
hallada sin vida en un tanque 13 días
después en el estado mexicano de nuevo
león en el que tan solo en los cuatro
primeros meses de 2022 han desaparecido
al menos 300 mujeres
y un nuevo motín en una cárcel de
ecuador dejó 43 reos fallecidos y 13
heridos se trata del capítulo más
reciente de violencia dentro de las
prisiones del país andino que en 2021
registró 316 detenidos fallecidos en
diferentes amotinamientos en los centros
penitenciarios mientras que las
autoridades aseguran que se trata de
bandas rivales del narcotráfico que
operan desde allí y se disputan el
control de las rutas hacia el norte del
continente
y sigamos en ecuador la corte
constitucional reconoció a principios de
este año que los animales silvestres son
sujetos de derecho al formar parte de la
naturaleza lo que significa que la
custodia o cuidado de estos seres vivos
debe priorizar la inserción o
permanencia en su hábitat la sentencia
busca frenar la tenencia y el tráfico
ilegal de animales en peligro de
extinción nuestro corresponsal en quito-
gustavo ortega visitó dos centros de
rescate y nos preparó el siguiente
informe
paul dirige un centro de rescate de aves
en ecuador una de cada diez rapaces
capturadas ilegalmente sobrevive es el
caso de gandalf un águila andina con
cinco años en cautiverio por baños
psicológicos no va a regresar a su
entorno porque corre el riesgo de morir
pero otras aves sí serán liberadas un
dictamen de la corte constitucional ha
reconocido el derecho de los animales
priorizando su reinserción natural que
tratemos a cada animal de mejor manera
para que no entre en estrés o depresión
y en la mayoría casos claro tratar de
liberarlos de reinsertarlos nuevamente
la naturaleza cinco mil animales son
rescatados al año en el país andino son
enviados a uno de los 50 centros de
rescate o zoológico de córdoba que se
agarra martín supervisa que sur un oso
de anteojos reciba el trato más parecido
a su hábitat fue sacado de una casa
donde una familia lo tuvo como mascota
acostumbrado al cuidado del hombre
durante 20 años no podrá ser liberado a
pesar de la sentencia
cuando tienen condiciones físicas o
comportamental es que no lo permiten
pueden ser mantenidos bajo cuidado
humano bajo cuidado técnico profesional
como zoológicos que estén debidamente
acreditados la sentencia de la corte se
desprende luego que una mujer
interpusiera un recurso de protección en
contra del estado en el año 2019 porque
le fue decomisado un mono a la nudo en
peligro de extinción que mantuvo en
cautiverio durante 18 años
entretanto en el centro de aves el
trabajo ha sido arduo más de 400
especies han regresado a su hábitat
y muchas de esas con emisores
satelitales que está nos ayuda al
municipio de quito para saber dónde hay
mataderos ilegales de animales
un nuevo habitante y en el centro y
rescate es un felino abandonar para un
rechaza la comercialización de especies
silvestres y lo acoge en su nuevo hogar
ecuador es un país megadiverso donde 91
ecosistemas coexisten su riqueza está
basada en su diversidad natural gracias
a una sentencia la vida animal valdrá
tanto como la del hombre y me despido
con imágenes de la obra de arte del
siglo 20 más costosa jamás vendida en
una subasta en 195 millones de dólares
es el icónico retrato de marilyn monroe
hecho por andy warhol y llamados shots 6
blue marlin el retrato pertenecía a un
fallecido coleccionista y la venta será
donada a caridad para dar atención
médica y educación a los niños se
desconoce quién la compró
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
joan y agudelo pueden ver esta emisión y
las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom
[Música]
i